we I mean that brings me I know I want a
slag on Beauty to Beast I learned a lot
on that show and I think we did some
very good work but we did have our
troubles with the network on that one
which again is indicated of what's going
on you need to be how many of you ever
watched beauty and a beast okay a good
number there it was a very romantic show
and we were nominated for Emmys we're a
very well-regarded show and and we had
pretty decent ratings never never hit
ratings we were watched like 97% of our
audience was women however which I
thought was fine but the network wanted
some men to watch the show and they were
always on us to increase the action
because they thought if we had more
action then that would get more men to
watch action is the network word for
violence they can't actually ever say
violence because then someone might find
it on a memo and they would be accused
of trying to put more violence on TV and
you know and they have the standards and
practices group that always reviews your
scripts that is telling you oh no this
is too violent it so be too disturbing
to the audience at home rip please
remove it please tone it down or
something like that and from the very
first time I started work even on
Twilight Zone where you know we had some
of the same problems but certainly I'm
feeding the Beast III bristled that the
hypocrisy of this you know because it
seems to me that if you're going to
present violence and then you there's an
obligation to present violence honestly
and to present it as things like this as
to as the knife through the through the
eye I mean Vincent was killing people he
was ripping people apart with his claws
is what he was doing in the action
scenes where he rescues Catherine but we
were never allowed to show any blood you
know at one point we thought you know
there was the classic beauty and the
beast that Cocteau did
labelled and Labette where the beast
when he came back from hunting his hands
would smoke and that was of course a
symbolic way of showing an artistic way
of showing blood and we kept trying to
come up what's our thing well we can't
use smoke cocked rosary used the the
smoke will you know people will say
we're just ripping him off so we can't
do that but we can't show actual blood
either so you know and the network
didn't even like the fact that he was
killing people they said we can't the
Hulk never killed people couldn't he
just destabilize them and like like what
well you know you should pick them up
and throw them a long distance and they
could they could bounce off the wall and
then we could see them get up and you
know say feets don't fail me now and run
away and terror I said didn't wonder
city be full of like thugs who have been
thrown across the room by a lion man you
know so know we finally got them to
allow that he would rip them apart and
it would go down and they would not get
up but we still would never allowed to
show any blood which means that although
in an intellectual sense if you watch
the episodes you know that he's killing
people but you never really feel it in a
visceral sense and it is necessary to to
feel it in a visceral sense and you know
we would do episodes like where he kills
almost no one or where it's all
character based you know an episode like
brothers that you saw earlier that's a
great deal of it is is psychological and
and they wouldn't like that they wanted
more action episodes more and more get
more action and we got to get some men
watching this show it's all just women
watching this show it's you know how we
gonna balance our demographics here
they're wildly unsecured and we never
succeeded in that but we became
unbeknownst to anyone we we became the
most violent show on television there
was a period there where the show hunter
which was on the same time as us was
really getting criticized as it was so
violent hunter hunter was you know like
shooting people with every episode and
they were dying and we actually like I
said we're
three times as violent as hunter since
its is killing way more people than
hunter
you know hunter is killing like barely
one guy in episode you know Vincent is
going in there with three or four thugs
and ripping them to shreds and leaving
their entrails and pools on the floor
but across we're not allowed to show any
of that you know and then after he does
that he reads a poem so so the lesson is
that if you're gonna have a lot of real
violent stuff have your character read a
poem afterwards and it just canceled it
all out of course you'll never you'll
never get any men to watch it then
because oh my god he's reading a love
poem quick turn to Hunter I might have
to hear more of this stuff so but at
course thankfully on HBO we don't have
anything we can present that